[Music]
you're a fast another significant number
on Monday as the continents death toll
from coronavirus exceeded 50,000 people
that's the vast majority of the 70,000
who've died globally so far but while
the infection is still on an upward
curve in some European countries in
others there are signs that the
contagion is starting to stabilize
Austria hopes to allow small shops and
garden centers to reopen on April the
14th with restrictions potentially
lifted on larger shops and hairdressers
on May the 1st but speaking from behind
a protective perspex screen the Austrian
Chancellor warned that everything
depends on the infection rate the
austere bokor Vienna in the wake of a
stir will be a deciding wake for us it
will be a week which will decide whether
the resurrection after Easter which we
are all hoping for can actually happen
as planned
the Spanish government is also studying
how to gradually ease the lockdown it
imposed since March 14th movement
restrictions have left poor and
vulnerable residents relying on
charitable groups like this one in
Seville to bring them food parcels but
on Monday Spain's or a fourth
consecutive days drop in the number of
new deaths and the number of new
infections rising just three point three
percent offers some cause for hope
relaxing the restrictions can't come
soon enough for those living beside lake
constance the barbed wire which once
separated the german turn of constance
and it's swiss neighbor croats ling and
was torn down after world war ii and
residents mingled freely ever since now
a new fence has created a coronavirus
no-man's land
separating friends relatives and lovers
like jean-pierre and his German
girlfriend November thore we've been
speaking to each other on FaceTime in
recent weeks and that's okay for a while
but after two or three weeks you realise
that that's not good enough we needed to
see each other and hear each other's
voice there was no other way but to meet
here at this fence in Italy's lombardi
region despite reductions in both
infection and death rates authorities
have actually tightened restrictions and
residents now have to cover their mouth
and nose whenever they go outside it's
an order intended to prevent complacency
but a shortage of face masks is creating
a problem
you could over no we cannot find
protected mass I haven't found them so I
made one myself
authorities say mass will be available
in three days but they've been saying
that for a month restrictive measures
are having an impact on the spread of
the virus and collective discipline and
a sense of civic duty are helping to
save lives and more people like this
woman leaving intensive care are
surviving but there are many thousands
who will not make it to this stage of
recovery and avoiding infection in the
first place still remains the safest
strategy Paul Brennan al-jazeera